PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATE
TORS. AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND HERE THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES.
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
OUR MEMBERS ATTENDING REMOTELY
TODAY ARE SENATOR MEN AND
SENATOR A TROLL BOOK. SENATORS
AS A REMINDER PLEASE MUTE YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. I S. THAT
EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USED TO
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ON MUTE. PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING. R. I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU WERE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU WERE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
IN THE GALLERY. TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WAS
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
THREE THREE SIX FOUR FOUR THREE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS.
EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO
EIGHT. FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
. AND OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
YOU WILL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. YES
THIS IS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT. AND YOU WILL THEN BE
READY TO ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE
. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE IN ADVANCE. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING A
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED.
I'M GONNA.
OKAY WE HAVE ONE BILL ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. WE'RE GOING TO- HOLD ON
ESTABLISHING A QUORUM BUT WE
WILL PROCEED IN THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WELCOME SENATOR WINNER
YOU HAVE WON BILL TODAY SENATE
BILL TWO TO FIVE. THANK YOU- MR
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR CONVENING
THE COMMITTEE TODAY FOR THIS
BILL. OUR COLLEAGUE SENATE BILL
TWO TO FIVE- HAS BEEN AMENDED.
TO REQUIRE A PERSON WHO OWNS A
VENDING MACHINES A POSTER
TELEPHONE NUMBER EMAIL ADDRESS
OR BOTH. ON THE MACHINE AND A
CONSPICUOUS LOCATION AS MAY BE
APPROPRIATE A VIOLATION OF THESE
PROVISIONS WOULD NOT BE A CRIME-
THE BILL'S AUTHOR SPONSORED HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIVE- THANK YOU SENATOR
WE WILL NOW MOVE. TO ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LYNC HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDING ACCORDINGLY
EACH SIDE WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED
A TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY. MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THE MEASURES. SO FIRST LET'S
HEAR FROM ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY. WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NONE WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TWO TO FIVE WE WILL
BEGIN. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF TWO TO
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO
POINT EIGHTY T. OPERATOR WILL
GIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE
QUICKLY PLACE YOU BACK INTO THE
QUEUE. AGAIN FOR QUESTION- JUST
TO TRY AND SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. AND WE'RE GETTING
NOBODY QUEUEING UP AT THIS TIME
. OKAY LET'S FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FOR MANY
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
FIRST MOVED TO WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. SEEING NONE. LET'S MOVE
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OF
ISTHMUS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH WITNESSES
. WAIT A TEST BY AN OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL TWO TWO FIVE WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO TWO TO
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR LET'S BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS IN
THE CHAMBER. OKAY IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR EDMUND WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM YET. COLLINGS
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS. OKAY SAYING NO
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
CENTER WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE HIS REQUEST FOR AN IRA
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN. THANK YOU
SENATOR. WE WILL NEED TO WAIT
UNTIL WE HAVE A CORE OF
PROCEDURE PATIENTS.
YEAH.
HE
SECRETARY LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO REMIND YOU
TO PLEASE SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE WITH SO THAT WE CAN
HEAR YOU. ROTH YOU'RE WRONG HERE
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA ARCHULETA
HERE BEATS. BACKER HIS DAUGHTER
YOUR DAUGHTER HERE A MAN HERE
EIGHT MEN HERE HER TADO. JONES
HERE DIMENSIONS HERE LLEVA HERE
LAVER HERE MAN HI HERE REMOTELY
. MAN IS HERE NEW MAN HERE WHAT
DO YOU MEAN HERE A SHOW ABOUT
OKAY. PRESIDENT A TERRIBLE ODOR
HERE PAN HERE AND HERE. WE HAVE
A QUORUM THE BILL SP TWO TWO
FIVE HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
EDMUND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL TWO TWO FIVE DO YOU
PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. RALPH HI
. HI MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA HI
ARCHULETA I'D BE. BACKER.
DAUGHTER HERE FOR FORTY FIVE YOU
MEAN HI MISS DODD THAT ARE DONE
HI I THANK GOD I HATE MEN BY
ADMIN I HER TADO. JONES LLEVA HI
LEAVE AT FIVE MIN SENATOR DID
MEN VOTING I. ON S. B. TWO TWO
FIVE. MAIN HI NEWMAN HI NEWMAN I
A SHOW ABOUT OKAY. THE LITERACY
EASIER JOB- SP TWO TWO FIVE I. A
TERRIBLE I CAN I CAN I.
YOU'RE
ON YOUR OWN. THE BILL HAS NINE
VOTES THE BILL IS OUT. THAT IS
THE END OF OUR AGENDA THANK YOU
TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED TODAY. FOR THOSE
WHO WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS. AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY. IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANKS TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE TODAY WE'VE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IS IT YOURS.